as good as i remember if not better it's
ridiculous they could just put this meat
in anything and it would be good you're
like rolled up in sushi it would be good
so good
i'm so happy we did this it's like you
forget the empire state building it's
like you come to nene's
[Music]
[Music]
our main dish here is the birya taco
beauty is a braised beef cooked for six
hours in its own juice so it's nice and
tender flavorful traditionally it's made
out of goat and also traditionally it's
in mexico you eat it as a stew not as a
taco in california you know they took it
to the next level they added cheese and
made it into a delicious taco attack was
so simple but at the same time so
difficult to create you have a lot of
flavors going on you have like the
smokiness from the media the chili touch
of spice to it you have the cheese
melting in your mouth and then you have
the compliments which are the onion and
the cilantro
so it's a nice mix of everything you dip
the taco and the consonant it's the
juice that the meat releases combined
with a lot of chilies condiments you
know just packed with flavors my name is
andres galindo and i'm the chef and
co-owner of nene stakeria here at
brooklyn new york
[Music]
we're in bushwick brooklyn
one of the hottest neighborhoods when it
comes to food art good vibes
this is my neighborhood it's my home i
went to school here when i first came to
the states i lived next door it was full
of cultures a lot of tradition going on
most people that immigrated to new york
city it's either from puebla guerrero
morelos which is like the southern
states of mexico
new york they call it puebla york
because we have a lot of people from
puebla
my mother immigrated in 1999 i was five
years old when i first came to the
states
around 2004 she opened her own
restaurant los tres marias it was this
more intimate place right like two
blocks away from here i grew up there
working every weekend as a delivery boy
dishwasher eventually making some tacos
i ranked up their yucasa
[Music]
yeah sounds a little lazy but
the love for foo i started there in my
mother's business i got inspired and i
decided to go to culinary school
[Music]
i graduated culinary school and started
my internship in jan george i worked
there for four years it was the best
experience in my life it was actually
one of my goals to work at that moment
in a three-star michigan restaurant we
had to learn a lot of ingredients you
know good caviar for bra you know
truffles we learned a lot there
i had quit jen george last year around
february three days later i had my
flight to mexico city i flew to mexico
city to learn more of mexican cuisine to
expand my knowledge new ingredients new
techniques new recipes
that same day i had my flight the first
case of corona
was detected in new york city
so i got stuck there i was meant to go
for one month i came back
after six months
[Music]
there were no jobs so at that moment i
told myself you know i got to do
something you know
this place came up right away i thought
like damn
why not like let's go for it and sell
tacos you know
regret
yeah she was the only one that believed
in me when he first opened so
nothing like your mother you know if
your mom doesn't believe you who will
i decided to open a video spot our menu
is focused in like the west coast items
i saw a lot of success out there with
beeria and i thought to myself why not
open just a place with viria
[Music]
it was tough at that moment a lot of
places closed down as you know in
restaurants was the most effective i
actually was worried but at the same
time was very positive that you know
people still got to eat you know and i
was selling comfort food which is cheap
and delicious at the same time so i knew
it was going to work out
the first day we opened i'll be honest
it was low we still had the cell phone
logo sign outside it was no one knew was
attack was shot
i started an instagram account you know
slowly friends were coming by you know
neighbors were coming by
now you have people coming from long
island the bronx you know even from new
jersey or connecticut you know how
social media works they see something
that looks really appetizing and you go
for it
[Music]
the way i see is like it's it's trending
like if a new phone comes out everybody
wants to have it you know you see people
eating this taco dipped in the sauce you
know you want to try it you know i'm
sorry don't take me wrong it's delicious
you know it's not only for instagram
it's also delicious
jj what's up brother pleasure man
something about the instagram photo drew
you in and what was that
it just looked delicious that's
basically what it comes down to welcome
to the old man of the three with jj
redick and tommy alter this is episode
50. tommy we need to talk tacos you and
i met in bushwick yesterday for what i
would consider to be a life-changing
taco i would agree it's certainly up
there for best tacos ever had in my life
it's up there for me as well
at all the places he came to bushwick
and to a delhi store to try some tacos
we really believe that this is one of
the best tacos in new york if not the
country and we also love andrei's story
yeah he came back to new york in the
middle of the pandemic and decided to
start this thing on his own it took a
lot of courage and it's a simple sort of
product and it's it's like perfectly
executed there it is here it goes thank
you let's go
and one empanada
thank you brother oh my gosh sophie a
little sticker tortilla amazing god
it's a musk
thank you thank you sir this is
fantastic thank you andres let's start
with the taco boss all right tip it in
yeah cheers
what is so unique about beer up is the
combination of flavor the tenderness
because it's slow cooked but also the
juice
you know that that stew that it's cooked
in it just gives it like a juiciness and
you add in that queso on those homemade
tortillas it's just a perfect
combination it's a perfect texture oh no
how many tortillas underrated and what
makes it so perfect it's like a great
burger having an amazing bun i would
agree with that this provides like a
balance for the rest of the meal the
wild thing is you know i spent a lot of
time in california jj played la for four
years we've had most of the best tacos
don't get me wrong i'm not trying to
slander la taco's an amazing taco scene
there but this is as good as it gets my
generation of players
like we were part of that sort of foodie
culture um in the late 2000s early 2010s
and we've passed that along to the
younger players so a lot of the younger
players are now into food they're now
into wine food for me has always been
sort of like a pursuit an outlet as a
young player my way to explore a city
was to explore the restaurants in the
city to explore the cuisine in the city
and then on teams where
you have a bunch of guys you hang out
with then it becomes about camaraderie
and building chemistry anything that we
collectively get into as a group we get
really competitive about it's like have
you been to this restaurant or you
haven't oh i have we knew right away
after one bite
we're like this is it it was a
life-changing taco
[Music]
[Music]
so the official grand opening of nina's
at barclay center will be in october
it's crazy it hasn't been a year since
we opened a phone store and turned it
into a taqueria and now we have a
stand at barclay center you know it's
been a blessed year you know the men use
five items three tacos some nachos and a
quesadilla you know it's a sport venue
and you want a fast pace here you know
you want in and out
i'm excited i'm excited for what's
coming for me for my family it's a great
opportunity i'm most excited to have
here in my stand my mother she's been
there since day one she's the one that
showed me support you know she's the one
that invested in me
and you know she's already proud of me
and i know that once he comes here and
takes all of this she's gonna be proud
i'm just happy to showcase my food to
more people you know especially in a big
venue like this one of the hottest
venues right now they have a super team
coming up you know i'm really excited
especially coming from brooklyn you know
i'm a brooklyn boy so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i was never expecting to open a type of
shop in my own neighborhood you know you
know i always wanted to open a
restaurant you know become a michelin
chef
it definitely feels special to me you
know like i said especially in the same
street i grew up with same shoe i went
to school
[Music]
in a certain way i'm giving back to the
community too you know with good food
good flavor you know
it's definitely special you know
you can say i'm living the american
dream
i don't know if you know this but maybe
in
barclays
wow
all right so barclays is number one in
the league
basically it's gonna be my second home
for the at least a year
no i'll be spending most of my time here
so that's amazing
we need to buy a net season ticket we
need to have a conversation we gotta get
comfortable
[Music]
you